you know what to do
hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it's time to dive
right back into the deep and confusing
sea that is the nen power system of
hunter hunter but quite specifically we
are going to be examining the intriguing
subset of our use is a nen curse now
what exactly is an end curse well there
is no strict definition but it would
appear to be a detrimental effect cast
onto a target via the use of aura very
vague I know but don't worry because
this video is going to be explaining it
in greater detail using the primary
examples that the hunter hunted world
has to offer immediately though I do
need to draw a distinction specifically
from the art of manipulation because
while an end curse is a use of aura
meant to exert temporary or even a
permanent effect on a target this is not
the same as a pure manipulation based
use of nen such as the various types of
mind control present in the series that
area is an entire sub-genre of its own
and I think that the most valuable
distinction is that an end curse does
not allow its user to control the target
but rather inflict a condition upon them
and these curses may also come with
conditions required for the affected
individual to remove them as well it's
all very dependent on the desires of
those who can craft them and speaking of
it should be noted that nen curses tend
to spawn from a few select areas of the
nen ring and most of the examples I'll
be mentioning here either have their
roots in conjuration or omission and
despite what I've just said manipulation
can also play a big part in crafting and
curse Tatsu but not in its pure form it
needs to be used in conjunction with
either conjuration or omission and
assumedly a specialist is also able to
invoke an end curse if they so choose
but that's only because specialists are
capable of literally anything
however the areas of transmutation and
enhancement are not equipped to produce
an end curse effect well let's stop
talking in theory and take a look at our
first example of a fine fine and curse
which comes to us in the form of crop
oka and specifically the judgment chain
han-soo now this is the poster boy
example of what I was talking about
because it was created utilizing
conjuration omission and manipulation
effectively allowing crop agar to pierce
a targets body and wrap a chain with
what's known as the steak of retribution
around the target's heart and this stage
krupka is then able to issue his target
to rule and if said rule is violated
then the steak will pierce their heart
and instantly kill them so immediately
we can see that unlike pure manipulation
crop occurred is not have direct control
of his target he has merely imposed a
restriction upon them and for example
one of the more well-known uses was to
set a rule on over
that he had to answer crop ACCA's
questions truthfully and Duva gain of
course immediately bert this rule by
refusing to answer and thus the nen
coast took his life and another more
left field use of the judgment chain was
actually cropping it deciding to curse
himself in regards to his chain jail
ability specifically basically cropping
a targeted himself and said a rule that
his change l could only be used against
members of the phantom troupe and once
again if he was to break that rule then
judgment chained the curse would kill
him instantly the desired effect though
was to impose a condition on chained
jail to make it more powerful overall so
there are definitely some interesting
applications of self cursing available
in the realm of nen although they are
exceedingly rare even rarer than curses
themselves so these are absurdly
powerful indications of aura however I
should also point out that making them
as potent as the curse crop occur
created is very difficult in his case it
required a great mastery of conjuration
manipulation and emission to the best
his abilities could possibly muster and
a mission particularly needs to be noted
because as a natural conjurer that is
crop occurs exact opposite on the nen
rank meaning the crop occur has to
invoke em for a time to access the
appropriate level of a mission to engage
judgment chain and of course emperor
time severely reduces crop occurs
lifespan so it's not a desirable state
to turn to if he can't avoid it
so what I'm trying to say here is that
nen kosis is powerful and not something
that is easily crafted and they came a
great cost crop ago but that really is
the thing about nen curses no matter how
powerful they are and in the case of
judgment chain it's pretty damn powerful
they still do need to come at a balanced
cost which is quite a big price for crop
oka to pay but to examine this a bit
further let's bring up Exhibit B being
gained through who we all remember or
maybe don't remember as the primary
antagonist of greed Island aka the
bomber
well his entire shtick was based on the
idea of a curse in the form of his
hearts who known as countdown now gained
through like Rebecca is a natural Kandra
and countdown is formed through a
combination of conjuration emission and
manipulation the holy trinity of curses
and as much as I don't like gain through
as a villain personally you do need to
give props to him for once again being
able to effectively wield a mission
which as a natural contour like Karaka
is by far his least proficient area and
not only that he does so without some
sort of Opie technique like Emperor time
in any case countdown is a bit more
complicated than judgment chain and the
end goal is the guaranteed death of its
target rather than saddling them with a
rule in fear of death so basically to
activate countdown gained through needs
to touch his target while saying the
word bomber and
activate the bomb he then needs to go on
to explain both of his known abilities
in full one of those being little flower
which we aren't concerned with in this
video and also again true does not need
to explain his abilities whilst touching
a target he just needs to touch them
while saying the keyword bomber and then
he can explain his abilities at his
leisure to activate the countdown bomb
and after this is completed a bomb is
conjured within the target and a timer
of 6000 begins 6,000 watts you say well
at 6000 artificial units of something or
other that directly correlates to the
pulse of victim so the faster a person's
heart rate and therefore pulse the
faster the countdown occurs and when it
reaches zero the bomb explodes killing
its target and there is one further
condition to the power that this curse
grants which is that the entire ability
can be nullified if the target touches
gain through and states
I caught the bomber so unlike judgment
chain it is actually possible to remove
this particular curse you just need to
do it within a certain amount of time
six thousands miscellaneous units of
time letters and another painful kicker
for those targeted with the curse is
that Gunter who can actually detonate
all of the bombs currently planted by
touching his thumbs together with his
henchmen Savin bara and saying the word
release so that is some pretty damn
impressive power on display with this
curse but in the end it subscribes to
inflicting a target with the
debilitating condition as with all
curses and something quite similar to
countdown will actually appear later on
in the manga when crawler lucifer
acquired an ability known as the Sun and
the moon whereby he can mark targets
with either a Sun or moon symbol and
then if the Sun touches a moon then it
triggers an explosion and this
definitely fits the nen coasts category
because once again it imposes a
condition upon a target if the Sun
symbol you have imprinted on you touch
is a moon symbol then you're going to be
doing a bit of an explode there buddy
and not only that but it's also possible
to brand someone with both a Sun and
Moon meaning that they need to be
incredibly careful of their own body
parts touching rather annoyingly though
we don't know what particular brands of
Nan are associated with this cursor but
I would strongly suggest that it is our
three usual suspects and at this point I
should say that not all nen curses need
to be lethal it just so happens that all
the ones we've explored thus far are now
whether I would like to now present you
a man named knuckle and his name curse
hot to noon as hakka soiree now unlike
the other known curses we've examined
thus far
Kawara does not involve conjuration in
fact this is a strict mixture of
emission and manipulation which makes a
lot of sense because knuckle is a
natural emitter and so conjuration is a
far far away dream for him and
essentially how Kawara allows knuckle to
curse an opponent through the condition
of land
blow on them and lending a portion of
his own aura an adorable little mascot
named a peon that appears and applies
the concept of compound interest to
settle Endora requiring the target to
pay back the or in full which would
dispel the curse however every 10
seconds interest is applied and if the
number exceeds the quantity of aura
possessed by the target then they go
quote-unquote bankrupt and are forced
into a state of zetsu for 30 days which
effectively means that they lose access
to their aura so this is an example of a
more tame nen curse which really does
suit Knuckles softer and more forgiving
personality not only that but it's
another example of a curse it actually
allows the user an opportunity to get
rid of it much like Yin throughs
countdown although in both cases it is
exceptionally difficult to meet that
requirement but that doesn't mean the
curse is like crop occurs judgment chain
and necessarily permanent because nan
curses do have a natural adversary being
nent exorcists now granted net exorcists
are very rare to find in this world
mostly because nan is already a rare
concept and curses are a rarity even
amongst that rare concept so as a result
there isn't exactly a massive call for
users to get involved in exorcism style
hot sue but there are a few and probably
the best-known one would be up and
gunner who was the man responsible for
removing drop occurs judgment chain in
the case where it was used on crow low
and the two rules were set one that he
could not use nen and the other being
that he was not allowed to communicate
with the other phantom troop members in
furthermore a began he was able to use
his power to remove began to his
countdown hatsune so it's a nice little
utility piece to have kind of like a
hard counter to all nan curses because I
mean assumedly he would also be able to
remove the Sun and the moon as well as
Hawk Kawara although as with everything
else to do it nan it's not that simple
because every removal of a curse comes
with a negative effect being imparted
onto the exorcist in question so for
example in our bag on his case an N
beast appears with the size and power
based on the strength of the ability
exercised that will linger and consume a
peg on his Nana until either the user of
the original ability dies or our Ben
Gunn is satisfies the condition to
disarm the original curse so in the case
of gain throughs countdown
I've been gonna had to touch him and say
I caught the bomber to get rid of the
beast that resulted from his exorcism
now in regards to the case of removing
judgement chain on crawler
well this is a much more interesting
example because to be perfectly honest
we have no idea when I began to perform
this or what became of him after doing
sir as grafica is still alive and there
is no condition for judgement chains
removal other than breaking its rule and
dying so a band gonna probably is not in
a good state at the moment to say the
least but before we dive too deeply into
the world of exes
because that really is a whole separate
topic of its own the final avenue of nen
cursors I want to explore is that of a
post mortem nen curse now I have a whole
video on postmortem nan if you're keen
to watch it a link to which is in the
description below but if a creator of an
N curse was to die then chances are that
curse would only become stronger and to
come back to judgment chain as an
example once again after krola was
affected by the haan-soo the phantom
troupe just plain gave up on killing
Cora pika because his death more than
likely would have resulted in crawlers
curse becoming even greater and possibly
killing him or at the very least
becoming impossible to remove and this
can be an assumed application of all
name curses so long as the user of the
curse passes away with the same feelings
and detentions as when they inflicted it
on their target and for another
interesting case of this you could even
argue that NetHope toes top-scorer is a
form of nen curse that they inflicted
upon themselves commanding it to dance
beyond its limits and thus leaving PTO's
body cursed off to death although as an
unknown ability crafted by a specialist
we are unable to confirm what if any
brands of Nan apply in the scenario but
that is the basic breakdown of nen
curses essentially the infliction of a
debilitating condition upon a target and
yes that target can indeed be yourself
if you so desire which as we've seen is
not unprecedented and can lead to great
power nin curses are however very
difficult to pull off because they often
require a combination of a mission and
conjuration which are opposite
disciplines of the nen ring but it is
not impossible to reach that level or
craft them from a form of a mission and
manipulation which are much much more
friendly elements but what do you guys
think about nen curses please do leave
your thoughts in the comments below and
if you're keen for some more hunt onto
content then please do check out some of
my other videos and even subscribe to
the channel for regular hunt to hunt to
glory delivered straight to your YouTube
feed but for now this has been the new
world of you and I'll see you next time